[Musique]
oui
que puis-je pour vous j'ai vécu dans
cette maison entrée je vous en prie ça
ne me dérange pas du tout alors ça n'a
pas trop changé c'est plus propre
faites un petit tour si vous voulez moi
je vais faire chauffer de l'eau tes
cheveux rebrasse lui vers brest janvier
nous aussi
[Musique]
et voilà à un peu de musique
or je suis vraiment navré en cette
saison la chaleur devient insupportable
ça va on finit par se dire qu'on
pourrait en mourir
mais vous savez ce qu'on dit sur déry
mourir et c'est ça n'est jamais vraiment
mourir
mais dites moi ça fait quoi de revenir
après tout ce temps c'est bien un peu
étrange un peu étrange
j'avais mis des cookies au four avant
vous arriviez attendait un peu je
reviens tout de suite je veux pas vous
déranger
non non non non j'assiste elles sont
belles ces photos madame coeur je sais
votre famille mon père est arrivé dans
ce pays avec 14 dollars en poche il
faisait quoi comme métier mon père s'est
lancé dans le cirque
[Musique]
j'ai toujours été la petite chérie de
mon papa et vous vous êtes toujours sa
petite chérie berline
[Musique]
je déclare ouverte cette réunion du club
des ratés
on peut y arriver mais il faut rester
ensemble
[Musique]